There lived a girl named Dorothy in Kansas.
One night, she was sleeping with her dog, Toto.
Suddenly, a big tornado hit Kansas and made Dorothy's house fly away.
After a long time, Dorothy woke up.
Oh! Where am I?
Thank you very much!
You got rid of the Wicked Witch of the East!
Don't be afraid.
She is the Wicked Witch.
Thank you, Dorothy!
But where am I?
How can I get home?
Well, go to the Wizard of Oz in the Emerald city.
He probably knows how to get you home.
Also, here are the Wicked Witch's silver shoes.
Put these on, and they will help you.
This is the only way to the city.
It was a road made of yellow bricks.
Goodbye, everyone!
Goodbye, Dorothy!
Dorothy and Toto started for the Emerald City.
On the road, they came to a scarecrow who was stuck on a pole.
Hi, pretty girl!
Uh? Who's there?
It's me! Here!
Would you help me get down from this pole?
Ah, okay!
Thanks a lot.
By the way, where are you going?
We're going to the Emerald City to meet the Wizard of Oz.
People say that he is the only one who can help us get back home.